last time on the ozepik Diaries okay it's
day one was epic it's Tuesday May 9th
very small needle so week two second dose
I'm at .25 milligrams I actually have to
say that my appetite was small today
in its day two after my second ozempic
injection and I've had two coffees so
far because I've been up since 4 30 I
haven't been able to sleep and I have
had diarrhea four times already today
um so I feel like I'm bouncing back physically
but I have been so hungry so this is really not
curved my appetite at this dose hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp welcome back to Abby's kitchen [Music]
today we're going to be catching back up with
my friend Ginger on month two of her ozempic
journey talking everything from side effects to
stigma to success a quick disclaimer that this
video may include numbers calories and Extreme
Weight Loss discussions so please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive to your
journey also please note that the individual in
the series is not my client so any suggestions
are for general knowledge only not specifically
directed at her everyone's needs are going to
be unique and should be discussed one-on-one
with your health care provider so to catch us up
here Ginger did a month of 0.25 milligrams now
she's on point five and is just about to do the
one milligram dose so before we bring on Ginger
let's take a look at some of her Diaries you
know similarly to my journey on the 0.25 the
when I started 0.5 the first weeks was was okay
um the second week was miserable with explosive
diarrhea case in point I was playing tennis one
night and I couldn't even lift my arms it was
so bad I I had to bolt because I was gonna poop
my pants I have paid myself more times than I am
proud of hashtag childbirth but again I would say
this is pretty much to be expected anytime we're
titrating up we're gonna experience more of those
side effects if you're experiencing medication
related diarrhea I want to share a quick little
few tips here so first of all lots and lots of
water and in some cases you might want to consider
an electrolyte supplement as well two you want to
focus on low-fat low fiber starchy binding Foods
so things like rice soda crackers bread and unripe
bananas also pretty important to avoid or limit
stimulants like coffee though obviously I get as a
fellow coffee addict this is easier said than done
okay Abby I'm upping my water intake just for you
I know I'm not drinking enough thank you
Ginger amazing uh if you take anything away
from this video right here it's that if you're
experiencing diarrhea or nausea or both water's
your best friend like all those zenfic pamphlets
that I've read are like drink lots of fluid so
Ginger that's got to be your focus for this week
and like every other week in this journey I feel
like I have some like built-in support like it's
like my raw raw support system this drug like
it's not allowing me to over indulge and I'm
very grateful for that I would rather go slow
um you know I had a little bit of Chinese
food this weekend and so that didn't really
sit really well in my stomach so note
to self we should all know this fried
food when you're on a Zen pick and have your
gallbladder removed uh it could not go so well
um so lesson learned uh and I gotta up my water
I know that so this is all gonna be a process of
relearning what feels good to your body and
this is also a transition period where the
side effects are typically going to be the highest
so it's not like Ginger's never going to be able
to have Chinese food again without feeling sick
but once she gets to her active dose she's gonna
probably have to learn through trial and error and
collecting data what kind of foods feel best and
also how much of them and when you've struggled
with not being able to trust your own intuition
for so long it might actually take a lot of time
time to like rework that muscle so Ginger try to
be kind with yourself this is definitely going to
be a journey so I've had a bit of a crazy weekend
with lots of friends in town lots of drinking
lots of eating and I almost forgot to give myself
my shot it's my last dose of the 0.5 next week
I'll be up at the one milligram I'm down five
pounds officially it's a little less than one
pound a week it has allowed me to not overeat
I am getting a little bit of um indigestion
and of course the diarrhea is still there but
overall like I'm shocked but I have definitely
lost at least an inch everywhere which is in
my opinion really awesome two and a half inches
in the waist actually and two inches in the hips
okay so this is amazing right and I get the sense
that ginger might be a little bit disappointed
that she hasn't lost more weight and surprised
that she's lost inches instead but this is
actually generally a good thing because it means
that our body composition is changing favorably
and it's really the fat loss and not the weight or
BMI that matters when it comes to good health that
said it's highly unlikely that we would gain
significant amounts of muscle mass in just a
few weeks when we're just doing our usual modern
exercise the more likely reason in this scenario
for the inch loss but less like weight loss is
basically just fluid shifts from the diarrhea
and the hormone shifts either from the insulin
suppression or maybe menstruation or both that
said I think this is a perfect pace for safe and
sustainable weight loss I mean the biggest risk
that we see with rapid weight loss on ozempic
is muscle loss like it can be up to 39 muscle
which ultimately we don't want so I know that
gingers can be moving up to the one milligram
so the weight loss Pace might actually pick
up a little bit and if it does we definitely
want to focus really intently on having small
frequent protein-rich meals to support muscle
protein synthesis and to help curb some of those
side effects all right guys let's bring on Ginger
hi good morning good to see you good
to see you uh first things first okay
coffee yeah yeah cheers but where's
your water where's your water girl
oh I'm gonna be on you where's
your water I know I know
I mean I know I can't talk I should also be
having my water but I am asking because I'm
thinking in my head I'm thirsty I should probably
grab my water I've started this new thing where
not unlike with alcohol um I try to have a sip
of water between sips of coffee to keep myself
hydrated smart so girl you gotta get in on that so
how is the water thing going because I know that
has been a challenge for you that's the biggest
struggle say that's probably one of the biggest
struggles and probably feeding into some of
the you know the other issues that I've had
um in terms of the weight not
coming off as fast as I would hope
um but yes I know I have to up the water intake
especially because I'm working out all the time
and I'm just I know I'm not drinking enough
water totally and so I want to give you some
little quick tips I don't know if you're doing
anything like this but there are lots of little
great ways to help you encourage yourself to
drink more one the moment you just gotta make
these little routines basically so when you wake
up in the morning like as soon as you get up you
pee you drink a whole glass of water and in fact
every time you go pee if you're getting up from
your office you're going to the washroom I want
that to be your cue for having a glass of water
um before you go to tennis have a glass of water
you know we think about always like having sips
during exercise but I actually want you to try to
make that as well just part I'm going to hydrate
before I get on the court especially because you
know things are not always going so well once
we get into our exercise so that's a really key
one do you have any of those like big water jugs
because that seems to work for a lot of folks
too you know what I have a four liter one and
maybe that was just like but maybe that was too
too much it's too ambitious yeah it's a lot to
Lug around too so I'm exactly so get a one liter
two liter even and one thing I love to do is to
put little rubber bands on it and then each time
you finish you you've refilled it you're going
to move that rubber band down so that's going to
keep you kind of you're keeping a tally without
having to like put anything into your phone
which let's be real I would never personally do
you're super restrictive dieting I have that the
mind that doesn't really allow me to be free when
it comes time to like eat and drink and that sort
of thing and every time I get that diary going
it's such a mind Bender for me like it's it's
really tough so and then I get mad at myself
if I don't put that one glass of water in and
I just I'm really trying to avoid going down
that slippery slope again so for sure I I don't
want you to have to be overthinking this I mean
at the end of the day it's things like hydration
should feel intuitive but you are in this really
interesting part of your journey where you're
learning your intuition all over again um and
that's going to include water and it's going to
include food so just those little like things you
know that just keep you keep you motivated um also
make it flavorful whether it's sparkling water
adding you know Spa water with little lemon or
cucumber herbal tea also counts of course so you
know you make it enjoyable for yourself so that it
just makes it a little more simple to get that I'm
such a sucker for sparkling water so if you're
saying like that's a go-to then of course yeah
my kids call it Mama water that's how
much I love oh is that Mama water yes
and smell the water that's the Vodka yeah yeah
exactly we'll get to that Mama water later on
um okay so tell me girl how are you feeling
right now like today or generally symptom-wise
okay so the symptoms over you know the first eight
weeks of doing drugs which was if if anybody is
doing it or if anybody's going to do it it's
always going to be the same approach the 0.25
for four weeks the 0.5 for four weeks then you get
to the full dose at the one milligram which is the
which what I'm told and what my research is is
the therapeutic dose for diabetes and then the
dose for weight loss is actually two milligrams so
I'm not there yet I'm kind of in the middle I've
done the 0.25 and the 0.5 and my symptoms and and
I understand why uh it's a gradual thing because
it is it does it does affect you and it was very
bizarre like week one of 0.25 and week one of 0.5
were very similar in that I almost didn't react at
all like I didn't really feel anything week two I
was exhausted and I had insane diarrhea like it
was always week two for whatever reason and then
it would normalize by week three and week four um
so I'm very fortunate um sorry that that would be
my my calendar advice we're just coming through
I was uh I was very fortunate uh but I didn't
have a lot of the kind of some of those more
extreme symptoms that some people had like nausea
um I really only the my the two biggest symptoms
were not were were exhaustion and diarrhea correct
and I will say um that I yesterday was my first
dose of the one milligram so I'm finally up to
that kind of that higher dose um and while
the diarrhea is still constant which has
been something I've suffered from you know I saw
this in the comments about the diarrhea as well
um on the first video but I've suffered from
diarrhea for years it's not just you're just more
sensitive yes and and people will have where their
Baseline is and then it may be well controlled in
you know everyday life to some extent but then any
external stressor is going to exacerbate that so
has made it a little bit worse in that I find you
know I can't really control it like sometimes like
all of a sudden I gotta run it's almost like those
IBS symptoms which I've really kind of got under
control and then once I've added these I think
like I was playing tennis one night and I had to
like like pull out of my doubles match and tag
somebody in because I was running you know and
it's just not enjoyable it's so horrible um but
the first dose of the one milligram so far has
been great um the one thing I will say with that
is the exhaustion is to the next level like I have
fallen asleep in bed with glasses on TV full blast
I have had to take naps well yesterday I had to
take a nap today I could hardly get out of bed um
so that that's been something where I've been like
whoa what is happening that is really taking his
toll on me but no nausea nothing crazy to report
in that sense so I think I'm really lucky here
yeah yeah I mean you know every transition period
is going to be a new bag of tricks um so just
listen to your body obviously rest if you need
it uh know that the fatigue and the exhaustion
is uh not uncommon side effect especially as
you're upping those Doses and it does pass so as
your body adapts you will get that energy back to
get back in into tennis because I know it's it's
hard I've got a tennis match tonight and I'm just
like will I be awake for it good question I'm not
I'm not using the medicine as an excuse you know
like I'm not using this as an excuse or an out or
anything I really am trying to incorporate it to
be like a positive addition to my life which you
know it has been actually really fantastic in the
giving me cues giving me I don't even know if it's
I don't even know if I can call it a cue what I
can say is almost like it's a disinterest like I
don't find I'm craving the sweets So Much Anymore
um and this has really just been the last
couple of weeks if I'm being totally honest
where I've been like oh no I don't want that
oh no I don't want that whereas in the past I
would have just done it because I was bored
or eaten it because I had nothing else you
know like just because not there you know I'll
just eat it but now like it was shocking like
this morning is a perfect example I had half
a donut left over from yesterday in the past
I could have probably eaten two Donuts in a day
or that could have been my breakfast I had half
a donut left over from yesterday because I didn't
eat the full thing and even today I didn't even
eat half of it like this morning that to me I'm
just like I'm looking at this donut being like
Ginger yeah that must feel so incredibly
like freeing that you're able to see food
um in a lot of ways as as fuel as nutrition
as energy as serving you rather than you know
controlling you in a lot of ways um where you
you know you're just more prone to eat slings
it's in front of you because you're bored because
you're emotional because x y and z um and for you
to not have the constant like conversation
in your head of do I join not then you feel
guilty and then you know then you I'm going to
restrict more and that whole song and game that
is incredibly mentally Freedom what what a burden
to have alleviated off of yourself it's pretty
wild I'm not actually sure I ever thought this
was possible and like I mean to people who have
that natural intuition and that not like you're
so I don't think you understand how lucky you are
like that is something I've never had before and
I've never really been able to walk away because I
would have said oh it's half a donut it'll go bad
tomorrow I gotta eat it you know it's it's little
trying to process that if I'm being totally honest
you know wow um but hey here we are this has been
great I hope it only gets better what I hope get
you know out of this experience is to learn to
still you know I'm still reaching for that donut
instead of the eggs you know like I just and the
fruit so I do I do hope that I get to a point
where I'm really trying to service my body and
I know like what's I know what's better for me
but what's easier isn't always what's better and
I still am in this like oh I gotta wake up I gotta
go to work I gotta have my coffee got to do this
quickly and then I gotta get to it you know so I
know we all suffer from that totally yeah so let's
talk about diet I want to talk about diet for a
minute so like I mean you've mentioned that you're
off I mean I know you you're super busy you're
just like me and food has to be convenient so
um are there any dietary changes that you've made
at this point that you feel maybe helping you make
more nutritious choices or is it at this point
it's still kind of just like essentially the same
Rhythm or routine that you've always had however
you just feel like you don't want to eat as much
of it yeah it's still the same Rhythm and routine
I find what I'm I'm not I'm not going grocery
shopping and buying like a big load of groceries
to cook because I'm just like not gonna eat it so
I'm kind of I'm going and I'm buying a sandwich
or I'm going and buying like a salad or ordering
Sushi you know like I'm not I'm a single woman
you know and so it's hard I'm not cooking for a
family it's really hard I think to make full meals
it just goes bad um so I'm struggling with that um
and that's why I love when people come over so
I can cook for them you know and then I could
be like oh I really want this so I can have my
little piece like my little portion you know but
um yeah that that's still definitely a struggle
for me uh and it probably will be for a while
until I I get to a point where all of a sudden
I'm craving fruit and vegetables so and protein
yeah it's not my first go-to and I really need
to I know I need to make that a priority but
right now as I'm still kind of getting through the
motions of being honest and I bet I bet if I ate
better I'd probably have fewer symptoms right
yeah and that's what I want to talk and that's
what we want to talk about because I was watching
your clip where you said that you had a night you
drank a lot you had Chinese food you did not feel
good and so you have that intuition that drinking
a lot and having a lot of like high carb high fat
high salt Foods doesn't feel good and I'm not even
on those epic and I feel that way I think it's
just like part of getting old and so this is all
data this is all data that we're collecting um
so what I want you to do is to experiment with
having smaller frequent meals every few hours and
I want those meals to be focused around lower fat
protein because that's going to of course be
really important for protecting against muscle
loss as you do start to lose weight a little
bit faster now that we're getting into that
one milligram uh range there and also so I want
to make sure that your gut is feeling its best
because we know that you know the higher doses it
may lead to more GI symptoms the diarrhea um and
any kind of nausea things like that I want you to
feel energized so cottage cheese hard-boiled eggs
you can buy pre-hard-boiled eggs if you want to
make it super easy and fast no you're like okay
I can boil my own damn eggs I'm good okay uh
protein powder you know obviously do a big do a
big batch of like grilled chicken chicken breasts
cut them up put them in the freezer I mean make it
easy for yourself I know you're a single person so
cooking for yourself can often feel like a really
big daunting task but consider the food part and
doing this meal prep just as important as remember
you take your shot every week yeah that's a really
good point and can I ask you a question because
I'm actually not sure I know we've been working
together for a decade but I still don't know
um can you you you on the grilled chicken
because I love barbecue grilled chicken
and it's summertime and like all I want to do if
I'm eating chicken it I want it to be on the the
barbecue can I cook pre-cooked grilled chicken
and then freeze it yeah no no I always do I I
mean you know cook whatever you can as many
as you can and you could put you know slice
it up put it into its own little Ziploc bag
in the freezer so you've got one portion at a
time you're just pulling out what you need
it's a great way to meal prep when you're
just one person and you can do that with
any other protein as well and then do you
microwaved it depends on stir fry throw it in
Frozen stir fry it up of course you just want
to make sure that it's cooked you know hot
all the way through and you're good to go
it's a great way to save time so that's that's
the struggle of mine like I always like I buy the
protein I freeze it and then I ever take it out
the freezer I know so I'd rather if I'm going to
the barbecue I'd rather like Mass cook Mass cook
Mass cook it all girl yep that's what I want you
to do that's really what I want you to focus on
this week so next time that we talk I want to hear
that you are freezer it's full and you're rotating
out like a like a meal prep master I love it okay
people watch we're gonna probably be like
this is so dumb no no uh no no no no no
no no I mean all of these I bet you there's
a lot of people who who don't even have you
know no ideas in in this in this realm so this
is gonna be really helpful for a lot of people
um but the last thing I want to talk to you about
is you know emotionally and psychologically like
let's talk about stigma let's talk about you know
now your story is kind of out there for all to see
um I don't know how open you were with friends
and family before deciding to go go through
this with me but like how are people responding
when you tell them that you're on ozempic and
or or do you tell them yeah um you know just
like likeing down diet culture I am trying to
make it a point you know to to to
Really tear down the stigma around
um you know obesity around being fat because and
I saw some comments on the first video about you
know you're not healthy if you're overweight
and I'm like actually I'm a mover I I like have
really clean blood work like I am if you saw
this on paper I am healthy you know I'm just
I just carry extra weight and I've been a dancer
my whole life well I mean prior to my 20s I'm in
my late late 30s now so not anymore it's been
almost 15 years since I've danced but you know
and I always carried a little x-rayed I was a c
body type and those you know you got the a body
type the B body type and the Sea body type
and I was always the rounder C body type so
um so I make it a point to be to fully disclose
that I'm taking notes and pick I will not hide it
I will not be upset about it I am looking for a
tool to help me it is not the be-all and end-all
I you know I think I've done enough research
and spoken to enough people and enough doctors
in within my circle and with you know even my
own doctors that to know that ozempic they're
calling it a miracle drug they're calling it you
know life-changing for people who and I I just
sometimes I think people just don't understand
what you know some people go through and
um so in that sense I've never had anybody say oh
my God you're taking us actually the response is
being super super positive and uh so so that's
reassuring and that kind of reinforces you know
my objective to never hide it and I don't and
that's kind of why I wanted to do this with you
in the first place because I felt like and I know
you know I'm a deep empath and I know the guilt
that comes with hiding things and I just wanted
to be very open about it and also to relieve my
own guilt you know I wanted to have a safe space
and to know that there whether it was a community
behind me or you behind me or my family behind me
um knowing that what I'm doing is you know at the
end of the day going to be really great for my
overall health and what with what the doctors
are saying are is is correct that I will not get
diabetes and though I will not have you know heart
disease bring it on you know I I have been living
in fear of that and every every time I go get my
blood work done and we do my blood work probably
more frequently than most given my family history
and we're always looking at the blood sugar levels
and like I'm always nervous that this is going to
be the year that they're going to diagnose me with
diabetes so I'm just like here I'm here for it
um on the flip side where it's been really
fantastic in it's almost like that that tool
or that big sister or that the guardian angel
and they have the Angel and the devil it's like
that little angel who's like people you know
like you don't need you know what I mean and
it in that sense it's been so helpful it feels
like I've got this like Champion helping me and
guide me on the flip side I also feel like from
a personal mental perspective that I haven't like
been that 20 pound Loser on that
first month granted I didn't start
like huge like I started under significantly under
like 200 pounds like I wasn't over 200 pounds
um so I have less to lose but I'm not dropping
the 20 pounds right away I'm not dropping you
know like a lot of people so I find myself
going to Reddit Pinterest Google every day
to like find a new answer about why I'm not
losing the weight as fast or what are other
people's results been or trying to seek somebody
else who's going through the same thing as me
um which can also be a bit of a mine are
you gonna believe me a mind Bender mind
[__] works yeah we love it but it is a little
bit of a in that sense it can be a little bit
um of a mind and I'm really trying to move past
it but at the same time I'm excited I'm excited
about the journey to come so I feel like I'm just
trying to equip myself with all the knowledge and
everything that I possibly can because I'm excited
that this could be the tool to help me finally rid
myself with these last 30 pounds and also I think
it's important um just as uh just as an aside in
some of the comments as well some some people
were talking about like the weight gain the
weight loss first I think it's also important to
recognize that the last year of my life has been
pretty um traumatic it's pretty traumatic uh
and you know from egg freezing uh to having my
gallbladder removed to having the worst possible
case of RSV and followed by coven where you know
like I got every single symptom including like my
eyes were oozing yeah like that yeah it was so bad
you did so it's just been like and your dog got
like attacked oh yeah and then my dog got attacked
and then he wasn't eating oh God it was just wild
so I have I've put on 30 pounds and I cannot seem
to just like and so like not moving is really
detrimental to my I need to move I'm not the type
of person who can just has like lower diet lower
calorie diet and not move I have to move so a year
of not moving has been detrimental to my house my
my physical health um and so so here I am you know
um but yes so it's like part excitement so part
like wanting to equip myself with the knowledge
and I do feel like I am knowledgeable and I do
feel like I have done the research and I'm not
going at this blindly and I know what to expect
um so so I I'm you know I I just just do find that
similarly to what I said about picking up the app
and doing the thing there's always something when
you have a disordered eating habit that is
going to come up inside you no matter what
you're doing so I find that I'm I'm definitely
veering on that side of the OCD like obsessive
part of it um and of course you're very invested
in this process this is like you know this is this
is a big step for you and you know be the same
for most people taking any new medication that
is significantly going to change their life
of course people are going to be interested
in every symptom is this normal is this not I
don't want you to like to to over pathologize
yourself for that because I think that's all part
and parcel with this experience and I'm also so
grateful that you've you're sharing this your
your journey to help destigmatize weight loss
medications and anti-diabetes medications
because you know I think when the sentiment
online is you just should have worked harder
and dieted harder or exercise more you lazy fat
then that really sets people back that's actually
not helpful at all there are a lot of people we
know for whom just moving less moving more and
eating less is not going to significantly move
the needle and that may be because of their
thought patterns those behaviors those really
deeply ingrained behaviors childhood trauma
it's all worked in there it's not as simple
as just you should have done more so I'm really
grateful that you've you've shared this journey
I know everyone's just going to be following along
cheering you on guys please cheer her on we we all
really should be so excited about this and so
supportive you know for for all the folks out
there who are exploring these options so guys
leave some happy supportive lovely beautiful
comments like I know you know how to please get
in there um yeah but Ginger I'm rooting for you
and I want to see what the next month brings
of you know you're at your your first kind of
like month of a relatively therapeutic dose so
I think this will be big let's see how it goes
I'm super excited Abby amazing all right ginger
good luck thank you I will see you soon okay bye
well folks I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please give it the thumbs up give
Ginger some love in the comments if you've got
some questions that you want me to cover on our
next episode let me know below and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye foreign